[A radiologist places X-rays on a screen to
be read.]
[Narrator:] The management of cancer involves
the services of several disciplines.
Utilizing the judgment and skills of the surgeon.
The pathologist.
The internist.
And the radiation therapist.
At the very outset, it is important to determine
which modality of treatment, or combination,
will most likely benefit the patient.
And whether treatment is to be given with
intent to cure, or for palliation.
Radiation doses and treatment schedules vary
greatly depending upon therapeutic aims.
And the radiation therapist, like the surgeon
and chemotherapist,
is guided by the classic dictum, "First do no harm".
The objective: to deliver a cancerocidal dose
to the tumor
with the least possible damage to the surrounding
tissues.
In outlining a treatment plan, the therapist
considers many factors.
The general status of the patient.
The type and location of the tumor.
Its volume. Its expected response to radiation.
These and other physical and biological factors
will govern the selection
of the appropriate type of radiation.
Isodose charts showing the penetration of
the beam for a given energy,
will help verify the suitability of the radiation
for the particular location of the tumor.
Radiation therapy uses a variety of equipment,
providing a wide spectrum of wavelengths and penetration characteristics.
This low voltage, 100 kilovolt unit is suitable for treating superficial, thin lesions,
such as this basal cell carcinoma.
The 100 kilovolt unit produces soft x-rays
of low penetration,
which deposit most of their energy in the first few centimeters of tissue.
Generators in the 250 to 300 kilovolt range
produce x-rays of somewhat greater penetration,
useful for treating superficial thick lesions;
as for example, this tumor of the carotid gland.
Megavolt -- million volt equipment -- produces still harder, more penetrating radiation.
A two million volt machine, such as this resonant transformer, is suitable for treating deeper lesions.
Here, used to irradiate paraaortic lymph node metastases, in a patient with a testicular carcinoma.
Six million volt x-rays are produced by this
linear accelerator.
With a betatron, 35 or even 45 million electron
volt x-rays can be obtained.
The penetration achieved with these high energies
permits treatment at depths beyond the effective
reach of lower energy beams as seen in this
comparison.
As noted earlier, the energy from a low-voltage,
100 KEV unit is quickly absorbed.
And does not penetrate much beyond the superficial
tissues.
With approximately eight percent of the maximum
dose measurable at a depth of 10 cm.
Approximately 35 percent of the maximum dose
reaches this level with 250 KEV radiation.
The two million volt generator delivers approximately
50 percent of its maximum dose at this depth.
The six million volt linear accelerator delivers
70 percent,
and the 35 MEV betatron delivers a full 85
to 90 percent of its dose maximum at 10 centimeters.
Isodose charts used by the therapist in planning
treatment show the dose distribution in percentages
of the maximum dose for a given energy at
various depths below the skin's surface.
Each chart identifies the modality, the source
skin distance, and the field size.
The penetration of these high energy beams permits effective irradiation of deep-seated tumors.
In addition, at higher energies, the edges
of the beam are sharp because these highly
energetic x-rays are not significantly scattered
by the irradiated tissues,
either backward or laterally,
as is the case with low-energy radiation where
there is significant scatter outside the field.
The more sharply defined edges of the high
energy beam confine the radiation
more precisely to the treated area.
Another advantage of high-energy radiation
is that the maximum dose is not reached at
the skin's surface, but at varying depths
beneath it...
so that skin reactions are not a limiting
factor.
High energy ionizing radiation in the megavolt
range can also be obtained with relatively
simple equipment using radioactive isotopes
such as Cobalt-60.
The Cobalt-60 unit emits gamma radiations,
which are similar in penetration to x-rays
produced by a three million volt generator.
The gamma radiation from isotopes is indistinguishable
from electrically-produced x-rays of the same energy.
Of all high energy installations in use today,
more than 80 percent are Cobalt-60 units.
Here, used to treat the patient with Hodgkins Disease.
The quantity of emitted radiation is expressed in roentgens, a unit of measure of ionization in air.
However, the amount of energy absorbed in
tissue is measured in rads, the unit of radiation-absorbed does.
One rad equalling 100 ergs of energy absorbed per gram of tissue.
Absorbed dose, however, varies with tissue
composition and radiation energy.
As illustrated in this x-ray film, at low
energies -- 250 KEV or less -- there is a
significant difference in absorption between
soft tissue and bone.
because of the greater absorption of energy
by the denser, skeletal tissues.
At higher energies, this absorption differential does not exist, and the amount of energy
absorbed by bone and soft tissue is about equal.
This allows treatment to cancerocidal doses
in the vicinity of bone without producing
bone damage because of increased absorption.
This side-by-side comparison shows the difference
in absorption at low and high energies.
The effects of radiation are initiated by
the interaction of the x-rays or gamma rays
with the orbital electrons of the tissue atoms.
The displaced electrons and scattered photons
cause increasingly large numbers of ionizations
as they penetrate the tissue.
The released electrons act as chemically reactive
reducing substances, forming free radicals
and producing chemical damage, including damage
to DNA.
Damage to DNA may be reparable, or may result
in cell death,
clinically observable as tumor shrinkage.
The initial manifestation of cell death often
occurs at the time of mitosis.
This cell, which has previously been irradiated,
is about to divide.
At first it appears normal.
However, as cell division proceeds, the chromosomes
tend to clump together, and a chromosome bridge
can be seen to connect the two potential daughter
cells.
This abortive division is one of a number
of manifestations
of lethal cell damage following irradiation.
In general, the sensitivity of a cell to the
effects of radiation
seems largely related to its mitotic activity.
Cells which are mitotically most active are
usually the most radiosensitive,
illustrated here by this poorly differentiated,
squamous cell carcinoma of the nasal pharynx.
Among the most radiosensitive tumors are the
malignant lymphomas and leukemias.
Undifferentiated, squamous cell carcinomas
and germinal tumors such as seminomas and dysgerminomas.
Moderately radiosensitive are the well-differentiated squamous cell carcinomas
of the skin and mucus membranes,
adenocarcinomas, and some sarcomas.
Relatively radio-resistant tumors include
osteogenic sarcomas,
malignant melanomas, and some gliomas.
Radiosensitivity of a tumor however, is not
necessarily related to curability,
since tumors with a high degree of radiosensitivity
are often those which also show marked anaplasia,
aggressive growth, and wide dissemination.
In fact, the chances for cure of a cancer
by irradiation depend mainly
on its location, its size and accessibility, its biological behavior,
and probably on immunological factors.
The general condition of the patient is of
considerable importance,
and can significantly influence the patient's tolerance to irradiation.
Cancer of the cervix is a classic example
in which radiation therapy is given with the intent to cure.
With irradiation as the principal treatment
modality, recent five-year survival rates
free of disease were reported by a major institution as follows.
[Graph titled 5 Year Survival Rates/Cancer of the Cervix is shown.]
This patient was initially examined by her
referring gynecologist,
who biopsied a lesion on the cervix.
Examination of the biopsy specimen showed a moderately differentiated, squamous cell carcinoma.
And she was referred to the radiation therapist for consultation.
The cystoscopic examination and intravenous
urogram were within normal limits.
Blood count and chemistries were also normal.
Vaginal examination revealed a normal-sized, slightly anteflexed uterus
with a tumor involving the external cervical os
and extending into the left fornix.
On rectal/vaginal examination, the lesion
is felt to involve the medial aspect of the
left parametrium without reaching the pelvic
wall,
classifying this as a stage 2B tumor.
In order to plan the treatment, certain measurements are needed.
The anterior/posterior diameter is measured
and recorded on plotting paper.
The contour of the pelvis is then obtained
with lead tape,
and is also traced...
and superimposed on the appropriate isodose chart.
Treatment will be given through two opposed fields.
The dose contribution of the anterior field
is plotted.
And then that of the posterior.
This will result in a relatively homogenous
dose distribution in the volume to be treated,
avoiding regions of overdosage or underdosage.
Compounding of the doses contributed by each
field results in these summation curves.
The limits of the treatment field are outlined
on the skin and entered in the patient's treatment chart.
She will receive daily treatments of 200 rads
through both the anterior and posterior fields,
until a tumor dose of about 4,000 rads has been reached,
well within the tolerance of the normal pelvic
tissue.
Fractionating the total dose into small increments
over a protracted period results in greater
dose tolerance and favors recovery of the
noncancerous tissues.
The field size is optically simulated,
using a beam collimator, which is adjusted
to conform with a treatment field.
And the treatment is started.
If there are no interruptions in the treatment schedule,
the goal of 4,000 rads will be obtained in
approximately four weeks.
On the last day of cobalt therapy, the left
parametrium has returned to almost normal consistency.
And the lesion at the cervical os is now visible as a small, whitish area of neurotic tumor tissue.
Treatment will be completed with intravaginal and intrauterine radium therapy.
This permits delivery of a very high dose
to the central, most resistant part of the lesion.
And simultaneously increases the dose to the
lateral, pelvic tissues.
A tumor dose of the level attained by this
method cannot be reached by external radiation alone.
After cervical dilatation, a tandem is inserted into the uterine canal.
Followed by colpostats placed into the lateral
fornices.
The position of the radium-containing applicators
is verified radiographically.
These films permit calculation of the exact
dose delivered to the tumor and adjacent structures.
Examination after completion of the full course
of treatment shows the healed cervix.
Radiation therapy with a goal of palliation
is exemplified in this patient
with a six- month history of difficulty in
swallowing solid foods, and recent weight loss.
The esophagram demonstrated a mid-thoracic, obstructive lesion,
which on biopsy proved to be a squamous cell
carcinoma.
Treatment will be given by rotating beam technique.
On a contour of the patient's chest, radii are drawn from the axis of rotation to the
skins surface.
The axis is located at the exact center of
the tumor.
The radii will be used in the computation of the summation curves.
These indicate a maximum dose region surrounding
the tumor,
and a much lower dose to the adjacent organs.
The chances for cure in carcinoma of the esophagus
are statistically very small since metastases
are frequently present when the cancer is
diagnosed.
Nevertheless, one can usually obtain significant
palliation with radiation therapy.
This split-screen comparison shows the grossly normal appearance of the esophagus,
approximately one month after the end of treatment.
In addition to its use as a primary modality
of treatment, radiation therapy can be effective
in combination with other types of therapy.
For example, children with Wilms Tumor show
a higher survival rate when radiation therapy
is used, in addition to surgery and chemotherapy.
In this post-operative patient, irradiation
may limit metastatic spread by destroying
any cancer cells which may have been left
behind in the renal bed.
In some cases of this disease, preoperative
irradiation is given
in an effort to destroy tumor cells which might be disseminated at nephrectomy.
In recent years, the combination of surgery,
radiation, and chemotherapy has resulted in
a dramatic increase in survival rates in Wilm's
Tumor.
Radiation therapy also has a major role in
the treatment of many other types of cancer.
In a patient with carcinoma of the larynx,
with a lesion limited to one or both chords
and no fixation, radiation therapy can offer
a cure and has the advantage of preserving the voice.
This patient received a course of Cobalt-60
therapy over a period of 43 days.
One month after completion of treatment, laryngoscopy
showed no evidence of residual tumor.
As with all patients treated by irradiation, this man is now seen regularly for follow-up examination.
[Physician:] Mr. Benkowsky, you feel well?
[Mr. Benkowsky:] Yes sir.
[Physician:] How long has it been now? About
five years since [inaudible] --
[Mr. Benkowsky:] Five years -- five years,
longer than that...
[Physician:] Mm-hmm. And your voice stays
strong?
[Mr. Benkowsky:] Oh yes. Strong enough all
the time.
[Physician:] And how about the swallowing?
[Mr. Benkowsky:] The swallowing is okay.
[Physician:] You want to take your dentures
out and put them into this?
[Mr. Benkowsky:] Oh sure, I'll do that. I
can do that.
[Mr. Benkowsky:] Yes.
[Physician:] Now open your mouth up wide.
Now stick your tongue out and let me see it.
All right. Now say "E".
[Mr. Benkowsky:] "E".
[Physician:] Say "E" again.
[Mr. Benkowsky:] "E" .
[Physician:] Very good. That's fine.
[Narrator:] Whether used with the intent to
cure, or with the intent to palliate...
alone, or in combination with other treatment modalities,
radiation therapy has a major role in the management of cancer.
In fact, at some time in the course of treatment,
at least 50 percent of patients with cancer
can benefit from radiation therapy.
About half of these treated for cure, and
half for palliation.
[Radiation equipment is switched on and a
regular ticking/knocking sound is heard.]
[Images of different types of cancers pre- and post-treatment are shown.]
[Images fade out; ticking stops.]